-Our first guest tonight
is Emmy- and
Golden Globe-nominated actress
for her work on NBC's
"This Is Us,"
which returns
with new shows in January.
Her new holiday songs,
released as a two-track single
"How Could This Be Christmas?"
are available now.
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Mandy Moore.
Hi, Mandy!
How are you?
-I'm well.
-I'm doing wonderfully.
This has been a weird time i
between your visits to the show.
The last time you were her
was in September 2016.
So you have waited
for the entire Trump presidenc
until you came back.
-I know!
I just completely, like,
wanted to boycott the show
I guess,
during the Trump presidency.
-You were like, "I don't wan
to have any part of that."
-No.
-It's lovely to see you again,
and congratulations.
You're about to have a baby.
How far along are you?
-I am seven months.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Yeah. I'm getting --
getting towards the end here
but thank you very much.
-And you're having a boy,
which I can tell you
from experience
is a wonderful thing.
And I know when you were here,
you know, we talked about
how you watched YouTube videos
of people going through labo
to have triplets
because of your show.
Does it make it a little bit
easier knowing that
you're just
gonna have the one?
-Is that not normal,
to watch YouTube videos
of people having triplets?
-Well, at least
you had a reason.
It would be weird if you had
no reason to do it.
-Yes.
I've tried to actually forge
the trauma that I endured
watching those videos,
because some of them
are just downright terrifying.
So, yes, I'm very grateful
that I'm just having
one child at a time.
-You guys are back
to filming again,
and you've decided to sort o
take head-on the times
we're living in, from things
like the George Floyd protests
to living under quarantine
Is it surreal to be doing a show
that is also, you know,
art imitating life, I guess?
-I mean, I kind of would expec
nothing less from "This Is Us.
Like, we are a modern show
and so much of our show
sort of takes place in,
you know, modern times.
And so it would feel weird
I think,
to leave such pressing issue
unaddressed.
It's certainly weird
because, yeah.
I mean, we're living through
COVID, as everybody else is,
and we're shooting
in the midst of COVID.
And we have all of these, like
crazy COVID protocols,
which I'm sure you do, as well
at your show.
So it's certainly strange to
like, have to initially --
I think we're sort of
past this point now,
but, like, as an actor
when you're in a scene
and you're looking
all around you
and the entire crew
is not only in masks
but also in face shields
and other PPE,
to just sort of let that g
and to kind of be in the momen
was definitely, you know,
a bit strange at first,
but now it feels -- it feels
like, you know, second nature.
-Also, I know, early on,
obviously, in the first season
of the show, you had to wear
a fake pregnancy belly.
Are you a little upset now
that they have not written
your real one into the show?
-I know.
It's funny because
the trajectory of our show is,
we sort of jump around in time
all the time.
So I am constantly --
In fact, the very first episod
I was in, we sort of, like, took
it back to going to the hospital
to give birth
to the triplets that day.
So I was in, like, the full,
heavy, like,
eight-month prosthetic
triplet belly and boobs
and, like, the whole thing
and I'm like, "Geez Louise
could we not, like,
postpone this for just
a few more months, and I could
you know, help out a little bi
myself with my own body?"
But, of course, I think,
like, true to form,
by the time I am, like, waddling
around at nine months pregnant
we'd probably be shooting
something where I'm supposed
to be like 25 and fresh-face
and getting married
or something ridiculous.
-Right.
-So, just --
just what I sort of
come to expect from this job
-So you decided to record
a couple of holiday songs.
How did this come about,
the decision to want to do this?
-So, I put out a record,
called "Silver Landings,"
earlier this year, and we were
literally four days away
from going on the road,
my first time touring
in 13 years, and COVID hit
and, obviously,
the world sort of had to shift
And so, I've been home
with my husband, obviously
like most people quarantinin
for the last eight
or nine months.
And a couple months ago,
it just sort of struck me that
in order to expend sort of this,
like, pent-up creative energy,
it might be fun to not onl
record a cover of, like,
a classic Christmas song,
but then try our hand
at writing one,
and I think
"How Could This Be Christmas?"
was the original that we wrote
and it sort of really reflects
on, like, this very specific
and strange holiday that we're
all going to be living through
and sort of rooted in the idea
that, really, it's about
togetherness and connection,
and that's something
that is gonna look
a little different this year
You know?
-When you decided a cover, like,
did you have a lot of choices in
front of you or was it obvious
-Sure.
You know, considering that
we were gonna acknowledge
what this holiday was,
specifically, in 2020, wit
"How Could This Be Christmas?"
we thought it would be, like
a perfect bookend
to "The Most Wonderful
Time of the Year,"
like, by Andy Williams.
Just, I mean, I felt like it
sort of covered, like,
the spectrum of emotions
that we're all gonna be feelin
during the holidays.
-I feel like everyone
will slowly be rotating
back and forth between those two
of, "This is the Most Wonderfu
Time of the Year"
and "Oh, my God.
This is a hellscape.
I don't care how many ornament
are on the tree."
I mentioned in the tease -
you probably weren't on yet --
but we were in a film together
You remember
the name of the film, right?
-"American Dreamz," yeah.
-Yeah, well, guess what.
Hugh Grant was on the show
and he had no memory
that he ever worked with me.
-Oh, that is so deflating
and disappointing.
[ Laughter ]
But I guarantee, by the way,
he probably has no idea
that he worked with me, either
-No. When I told him
the name of it, he's like,
"Oh! With Mandy Moore.
She was wonderful."
[ Laughter ]
-No, really?
-No, but still...
-Yeah, see? Exactly.
I swear, I crossed paths
with him at an award shows
and I was like, "Hi,"
and he looked at me
like I had four heads.
-Wow.
-So, I'm -- I'm --
He's a lovely man, but, yo
know, he does a ton of movies.
I don't know.
But I will never forget.
I had the best time with you
-We had a great time.
-I came out of that projec
going, like, "Seth Meyers
is probably the funniest perso
I've ever met in my life."
-Right. You were like,
"Not the best actor..."
[ Laughter ]
"Like, I wouldn't be surprised
if this was
one of his last movies."
[ Laughter ]
Mandy, I have great memories
of that,
and it is always
just so lovely to see you.
Thanks so much for being here.
-Thank you for having me.
Good to see you.
-Her new holiday music,
"How Could This Be Christmas?"
is available now.